hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play don't look now
okay I'm not even gonna bother to read
to explain this so I'm just gonna read
the instructions navigate using the WASD
key in the mouse to look around don't
look at them who's them oh they will
hunt you who's they
and drain you of your last sanity if
they catch you who's they keep an eye on
the neurons firing fight them off by
rapidly pressing the Q key whilst trying
to regain control of your vision and
movement when in doubt the trees might
provide answers direct your
consciousness and reach your happy place
okay alright then here we go whoa oh
right into it hello that's a lot of
post-it notes okay so I still don't know
what the hell I'm not looking at oh
that's my neurons down in the bottom
right there I think it's kind of cool
actually this is made on the Unreal
development kit which is a free
development kit that's released to
everybody whoa which gives you all the
tools and quite a lot of Education you
need to learn how to make your own games
like this and this really cool Wow
whoo who's that tree can you give me
answers boom who's there who's there
who's there what's in there what's in
there what's going on hey hey what's
going on what the hell okay I'm utterly
confused I hear breathing who's our oh
god oh god oh god we got something what
is that
okay thank you for nothing
I tried to run away from it apparently I
have no sprint okay hi buddy okay so
that's the thing I'm not supposed to
look at but how do I get by it
oh how do I get by you join me Barney
boy you okay alright then let's try this
again no look at it don't look at it
don't look at it don't look at it don't
look at it don't look at this look at
this don't look at it don't look at it
don't look at it don't like and I got
down open door open door opener [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
Frick frack Fraggle Fraggle Fraggle tre
give me an answer but the hell are those
things
I'm not looking at him definitely not
looking at him what see what trees
aren't giving me any answers
QQQ oh I need to fight them off with Q I
forgot about that I totes forgot about
that
thank you I fought it I fought it off
with the Q button
hey look it's another tree
what is this just water what's going on
what is going on what's the deal yo I
found a tree have I found all the trees
or something oh I don't like this
reminds me of that yo scene from Bruce
Almighty we put a post-it notes whoa
I am a ghost within McClellan goosed
spirit no one knows oh no I just summon
the demon within itself I think maybe
was this door - no okay so where the
hell am I going
I hear you [ __ ] breathin well what
am I supposed to do okay you you you
five high five high five PI pi PI pi PI
pi PI alright so how about them trees
giving me the answers and all that whoa
hello okay alright moving forward Jesus
what the hell is going on here
oh I gotta go by him ah not like a job
finding your footing by fighting but
finding out I'm fighting you i feii out
bought him off holy balls I didn't think
I was gonna make that one holy crap I'm
a dyke huh oh that tree that's a tree
let's drive man drink fight fight fight
fight fight fight fighting fighting
fight the [ __ ] out here get outta here
get outta here get out of your tree
Jesus that's hard to fight okay I got
another tree maybe I think I beat the
[ __ ] out of him I think I oh man I think
I totally destroyed that a-hole oh man
that was a hard one oh man don't kill me
don't kill me don't kill me rose oh god
there's another one down that way that's
another one
what about your products on the end of
the console
oh I was fighting as hard as I could
guys that just wasn't enough come at me
bro
you ain't got [ __ ] on me oh god why the
cue button of all the buttons why cue
spacebar anything but the cue button
okay moving war ah where'd you come from
no no no no no no no no
no no no aah what I had that bollocks
giant bollocks where am I
I had that okay oh no not that way
definitely not that way okay you you
want to mess with Mary come on come on
ah [ __ ] baloney pull Oni
Bellona flew where the hell am I going
oh okay
I went the wrong way all right [ __ ]
maybe that's it oh okay I gotta do a
combination of not looking at him and
whoa whoa whoa what a hack
Jebus oh man where what is happening oh
man his ridiculous
okay let's look normal
tree give me some answers trees with
stuff on the walls Jesus I could not
perceive blood it cost no heroes left
being in the world Sun shadows is more
over here what is this Sun shadows the
spots that bore through my head and make
me Spacey
Kevin Spacey okie dokie oh I'm gonna
jump into this orb because that makes
sense
alright then where am I now I'm outside
in a desert was not a wonderful
oh oh of course not
things aren't gonna be just fine and
dandy things are not okay
where am I where I where I lie where am
i oh crap I feel like I am trapped
inside my head banging against its walls
whoa
things are getting kind of weird
they were weird awhile ago but now it's
getting extremely weird trying
desperately to escape while my lips can
utter only nonsense oh man all right
then
good it's like blood trees or blood
roots to the inside of a head maybe I
don't know the story I'm trying to piece
together a story here but it's kind of
confusing and not giving me much to go
on
probably another directive of taking a
trip inside the mind of insanity it's
not an uncommon theme in horror games
but this is a definitely definitely an
interesting take on it man I gotta agree
I'm more confused than anything maze of
pain and fear
okay which way do I go this summer in
there there is not no escape the whale
world is the whole world is poisoned the
whale world is poisoned
oh hello by the music stop
why can't I change what the hell what
the hell breath breath breath what the
hell what's going on I even know man
I'm so confused
I'm so confused which I think it's a
point as I walked I say as I walk the
ground crumbled beneath me and I could
make no movement [ __ ] you oh man I'm not
even going to give that thing the time
of day
okie-dokie what's that floss snip as
they're experiencing my body is a
machine that I could see and feel who is
rpts what who is our pts who is that
whoa there's another one in the corner
there I just barely saw him before I
walked right into him there is no escape
the whole world is poison okay all right
then this is perfectly normal
everything that's happening right here
whoa oh I see them let's uh now look
let's not go there let's not go there
how about that let's not go there at all
so I'm definitely inside the mind and
this is taking a more literal sense uh
crap a more literal sense of it's
actually inside the brain that's what
I'm pretty sure this whole environment
and world is about okay I've got to go
in here I'll did look at the ceiling
[ __ ] I see them all they're all they're
all upsell boat
no no no aah ha I beat the [ __ ] out of
both of you hmm
I'm the greatest ok got some MC Escher
[ __ ] going on here trying to find my way
to some sort of mystical tree tree here
ok I might have been enough that might
not have been I don't know ok maybe that
was the only tree in here let's find out
let's get the hell out of here I know
you don't I'm too tough for you oh man
there's trippy beyond words I mean if I
was high this would probably make the
experience 10 times more awesome it's
still pretty awesome I'm very impressed
by this game ok the doors open here can
I do something about that ah crap don't
tell me it forked up right here don't
tell me the game forked up right here oh
no wait whoa almost add some there oh
there we go got it nailed it nailed it
ok I hear you I hear you I'm not gonna
look at ya but I hear you get out of
here F of F Oh what is this a door I
need to find one more tree in here why
are there trees inside my head at least
I'm assuming this is my head and not
someone else's head that's another one I
gotta find another tree I just got to
fight off these monsters these monsters
ain't so bad anymore now that I know how
to beat them
okay come at me bro come at me brews
anybody where are they
ah there's a tree I think there might be
another tree so let me go look at oh I
see an arm floating through there I see
a guy
fu okay there's got to be another tree
this guy is over here probably guarding
the last tree hi you're big you're big
angel go away
what no tree alright maybe those it wait
I think I hear one more breathe you guy
AHA there you is come at me bro
even lift even lift ok so that's where I
came in how did I dodge that guy he was
like right there ok so maybe that one
tree got both of the doors I guess I
didn't really need to confront any other
guys ok this one is still closed hey
that's not even a door then the thing
over here is open for business
ok oh whoa whoa no thank you I don't
want any no thank you
that guy was big ha ha that's what she
said yeah uh-oh
oh man this game is just getting freaky
I would like you know in a game more of
a narrative
let me check under the stairs there's
all he tell none of the stairs except
when they're not they're not I would
like a bit more of a narrative but
exploring insanity is is pretty cool by
itself and I mean the level design is a
very trippy to say the least
I mean with these short indie games it
can be hard to tell an entire story
eloquently and succinctly so on with the
shorter games it's often you you you
surrender some of the story in the hopes
that the story will tell itself through
the gameplay that's fine
that's that's fine as so long as it
works what the
wait a minute Oh was I supposed to out
that's this window here oh hello whoa
what whoa what's going on what's
happening mom back out here again oh man
oh this is my happy place that's right
I'm trying to find my happy place oh I
get it okay yeah see this game it's
working the story is actually working as
it's being pieced together I'm
understanding more of the story the more
I continue through it and that's good I
definitely appreciate it and it's going
wrong it's all going so wrong ah you got
me again looks like I'm not gonna be
able to escape my nightmare where am I
now it's all white what was it
hello
Maes of pain and fear okay it is indeed
isn't it well where am I going
whoa what the hell oh no you don't
oh no you don't oh I see you I can't I
hope I'm going the right way man
this is cool whoa holy crap this is like
taking interesting gameplay to a whole
new level this is wonky aha found my way
out man I guess I just got to follow the
spectral trails this is so trippy I see
you there hi buddy hi buddy okay not
looking
got ya okay it branches off so let's go
right
this is so freaky okay where does this
go it went nowhere okay let's go the
other way now and it branched off again
this looks like it's got more to it
aha there we are I wonder how long it
took this the game maker to make this
and I wonder if you had help I mean a
lot of the textures are simple textures
in comparison to everything else but I
mean that's not a bad thing okay can't
see anything there's a little something
there but it's mostly just washed out
aha
this way whoa what dead gloor snob
enough I've gone but the too hot so hot
oh so hot
too hot oh oh sorry sorry sorry my
apologies
okay so what was that what was it oh
here we go it's awfully harder to see
the black on white as it is see the
white on black with the tendrils man
it's like impossible to see anything I
hope I'm going the right way
oh man this is a this would be terribly
easy to get lost in whoo okay the music
is like slowing down actually kind of
dropping okay the music is gone now will
maze of fear oh no did I just go in a
big-ass circle ah balls what you're
kidding me oh [ __ ] I just went in a
big-ass circle ah balls
damn it how the way maybe I didn't know
let me not be so hasty here let me not
be so hasty I may have because I was
definitely at the beginning but I
definitely went straight forward so I'm
not so sure maybe there was something
else here aha wait no ah piss wait
what's this over here
ah more aha actually I don't know where
I'm going now I might be going backwards
I might be going forward I don't really
know I don't think I'm backtracking
again but still that's like freaking
hard to deal with
oh man this is like the biggest mind
[ __ ] I've ever been through in my life
okay
I read that no I'm going backwards what
done where am I going
I don't even know anymore I am so
amazingly lost not even know I'm on left
oh where am i where am i that can't be
correct
cuz I went that way wait no what what is
going on here I am that is where I came
from that is the first place I came from
and somehow I got turned around again I
don't know man I don't know ah ha ha I
don't know maybe I'm just supposed to
wander this pert odds another one ok
maybe this is new maybe this is new
maybe this new
okay maybe this is new maybe I'm in a
new place I don't know I'm just
amazingly incredibly lost what does this
say oh the spots that burn through the
heart and walked up what is this who's
so lost
no you don't know you don't know you
don't know you don't know you don't know
you don't go I go I go I go I go I go
that's right f off and now cut quiet
again ah
oh I'm insane that makes sense
I'm very very insane
oh man sounds like that had to be the
biggest mind [ __ ] of a game I've ever
encountered in my life holy balls I mean
I'm not saying is like the best game
ever there was obviously some flaws I
mean the art wasn't incredible but this
is a big team to work oh no it's all the
same name over and over again so I mean
it's a small team but really well made I
really like the way the story was slowly
and steadily pieced together by the user
it wasn't told it was shown and when you
show a story as opposed to telling a
story that's a lot better in a lot of
ways and it works for this one I mean
the end of the level was confusing but I
mean it was supposed to be a maze like
you're trying to find your way through
your online but kind of sad that it
turned out that he was just plain old
insane insane in the membrane the entire
time but so the most frightening part
for me is how quickly I can be taken as
if by a force and projected into another
state in which all my perceptions are
altered and the world becomes a bizarre
place sometimes there is confusion about
which is the true reality the objective
world or the psychotic world Anonymous
okay so no that was released in 2010 I
thought it was a newer game but oh man
that was great I really enjoyed that so
I hope you did too click the annotation
for more videos set I've done check the
description for a link to the game so
you can play for yourself thanks again
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
oh [ __ ] I remember with us
haha